hablábamos ahora de economía aquí en
directo américa de france a 24 ya está
conmigo en el estudio por supuesto con
resultado jorge iniciamos en europa con
el dato de la inflación así de raúl y es
que la inflación en la eurozona se
disparó al 5.1 por ciento los precios al
consumidor en los 19 países que usan la
moneda única subieron 5,1 por ciento con
respecto a enero del 2021 según la
agencia eurostat el aumento fue
impulsado por los altos costos de la
energía que fue en un año 28 6% pese a
que la inflación es más del doble del
objetivo del banco central europeo los
funcionarios sostienen que este aumento
de los precios se debe principalmente a
factores transitorios y que la inflación
volverá a caer por debajo del 2% a
partir del 2023 el consejo de gobierno
al banco central europeo se va a reunir
este jueves y se espera que mantenga la
política monetaria sin ningún tipo de
cambio aunque esta cifra podría hacerlo
replantear esa posición los inversores
apuestan a que el banco central va a
endurecer su política con respecto a los
tipos de interés como lo han hecho ya
otros bancos centrales del mundo oigamos
ahora hablar del aumento de las remesas
en méxico así es el incremento del flujo
de remesas en 2021 fue más del doble de
cualquier año anterior los mexicanos
recibieron 51 mil 594 millones de
dólares en remesas en 2021 una cifra
histórica y reflejo de la dependencia de
las familias en el exterior según
confirmó el banco de méxico las remesas
de 2021 en el país azteca experimentaron
un aumento anual del 27,1 por ciento
frente a los 40 y 1600 millones de
dólares que también fueron un récord
durante 2020 según economista las
remesas son la segunda fuente de
ingresos de dólares de ese país e
incluso son el doble de la inversión
extranjera directa que recibe en mexico
y supera los ingresos por turismo pero
las remesas no pueden atribuirse a un
logro generado por méxico más bien se
relacionan con la alta falta con la
falta de empleos y el lento crecimiento
de esa economía donde las familias deben
migrar para enviar ingresos a sus seres
queridos y hablamos jorge de otra cifra
récord y estamos entonces a punto de
conversar sobre la deuda pública de
estado y así es la deuda pública en eeuu
superó por primera vez el umbral de los
30 billones de dólares según datos del
departamento del tesoro
la cifra fue empujada por un incremento
de 7 billones en los últimos dos años
que coincidieron con la pandemia de kobe
19 la administración de trump y luego de
joe vaivén emitieron gigantescos planes
de estímulo para evitar un colapso de la
economía desde el 2000 desde el 2020 el
gobierno aumentó los beneficios de
desempleo así como ayudas directas a las
empresas de los 30 billones de deuda
pública 23 -cinco pertenecen a
acreedores y 6,5 billones restantes es
deuda contraída por el gobierno consigo
mismo el pasado diciembre demócratas y
republicanos debatían aumentar el techo
de la deuda al final ganó el consenso y
bailén firmó una ley que evitó que el
país se incurriese en una suspensión de
pagos por primera vez en su historia
para algunos analistas la deuda no es
necesariamente negativa dado que la
economía está en crecimiento con las
tasas de interés todavía bajas e
inversionistas dispuestos a comprar
valores del tesoro de eeuu aunque aún
persiste la preocupación del déficit
presupuestario es la brecha entre lo que
el país gasta y los ingresos que genera
jorge le gustan los carros eléctricos
bastante bueno y se tiene que ir
entonces a europa porque ahí se están
tomando fuerza así es las ventas de
carros híbridos operaron por primera vez
a la te dice el en europa aunque los
superaron por una brecha de 48 vehículos
en este continente uno de cada 11 carros
vendidos fueron de batería eléctrica se
vendieron casi 880 mil vehículos de este
tipo ahora los carros híbridos que son
auto recargables tienen una batería
cargada por un motor de combustión
interna y pueden recorrer cierta
distancia con energía eléctrica en 2021
se inscribieron en la unión europea'
casi 2 millones de carros híbridos de
carga automática esto se representó un
salto importante respecto a los 1,1
millones matriculados en 2020 en 2021
las ventas de vehículos eléctricos de
batería crecieron un 63,1 por ciento
mientras que las ventas de híbridos
enchufados crecieron un
70,7 por ciento cifra el día sobre la
cifra del día de 62 mil 900 millones de
dólares esas fueron las ventas de google
en el cuarto trimestre un 33% más que en
el trimestre anterior lo que demuestra
que alphabet que es la empresa matriz
logró sortear los retos del cob y 19
para su gigantesco negocio publicitario
gracias jorge por toda la información
nos vemos mañana con más economía en
directo américa nos vamos directo hasta
país
[Música]